it's crazy and really it should be known
and sent to the dpin of stupid
[Music]
ideas the interesting thing is that
we've seen a major tragedy of decomm in
the sea and it started really with what
was called the Great acceleration after
the second World War there was a fear of
famine there was a fear of that we
needed food and governments started to
give huge subsidies to Technologies and
long-distance fishing capacities and as
a result of that period peren Nets
developed well over a mile long catching
everything in their wake long lines of
10,000 hooks lasting 20 miles have
developed whole series of fads fishing
aggregation devices developed and there
are now well over a 100,000 out there in
the sea in the course of my research for
this book I've been off about 20
countries and often I've bumped into
some of these fishing aggregation
devices and they're left to just Escape
when they when they the company has fed
up with them and they've got something
better they go off and they cause a lot
more pollution so the initial period of
the great acceleration was what I call a
neoanal period and it was an
encroachment because gradually fishing
was going further and further from the
shores the more conflicts out in the sea
between between countries from different
nations and so on and it was a period of
encroachment
but the big event started with
enclosure I ask in the book The chapter
begins who owns the sea who owns the sea
well I can give you a more nuanced
answer Justina and codex said it was the
commons but in
1945 imperialistic the United States
said we are going to take our territory
way out to sea effectively 200 nordal
miles in what's called The Truman
Proclamation they acted imperialistic we
won the war we're going to demand and we
extend our territory by that amount
promply have several other countries
started doing it Chile Peru and so on
this led to gradual tensions until the
passage of
Enos which was
1982 I gave a talk in the House of
Commons recently when I mentioned the
word anos I could see the
BL oh that you
know across people's face now unclos was
described by the UN Secretary General at
the time as the most significant legal
instrument of the 20th century
and I agree with him 100% And what anos
did was try to resolve the increasing
tensions in the world's seas and the
first thing it did was introduced the
biggest enclosure in the history of
humanity an incredible enclosure because
what it did was that it said that every
Coastal country could have 200 nautical
miles from their shores would become
part of State State
territory okay now if I ask you which
country did best out of this I don't
think you'd guess I certainly wouldn't
have done so I'm not being too clever by
half it's France because France had a
lot of islands around the place they got
they got nearly 12 million square
kilometers of seabed the United States
got 11.4 they were number two then
Russia and Australia and Britain came in
fifth not too bad given that we gained
on that stroke of a pen in 1982 6.8
million square kilometers of
seabed that meant that the sea is 27
times as large as our land
area that's a huge change right and you
go down the list of countries that did
very well and you get sort of way down
the list and you find that little
country called
China that little country called China
got less than 1 million now that you
have to bear that in mind when you think
of what the geopolitical tensions taking
place in the South Pacific and elsewhere
now the enclosure was
arbitrary 200 nautical miles why why but
they added on that if you had a
continental shelf that was larger you
could get up to
350 and some countries have been doing
precisely that now the unclos which is
the United Nations convention on the law
of the
sea was a set of messy compromises they
had to get agreement from 160 plus
countries eventually we got an agree a
ratification by 167 plus the European
Union but one country
refused that country was the United
States so it's taken the benefits but
hasn't gone for the the commitments and
it was a set of messy
compromises the the countries with
coasts got their ezs exclusive economic
zones of 200 the great Powers got the
rights of navigation all over the world
the countries that were landlocked 43 of
them also got the promise as every other
country got that if there was deep see
mining then there had to be a sharing
mechanism for the benefit of all
Humanity for the common good of humanity
that had to be respected for all as
equals and there had to be a mining code
developed and what that this did I'll
come back to that story in a minute but
I just want to go through what's what's
happened with with fishing and then
aquaculture and then Mining and then
I'll I'll I'll come to my proposal
first of all part of
anos was designed in effect to respect a
nutcase who a name a main man named
Wilbert Chapman and Wilbert Chapman was
one of the first of the US
administration's people to be a to be a
nominated specialist for the sea in
1949 he must have had a few drinks I
think in 1949 he devised a concept of
the maximum sustainable yield
MSY and the maximum sustainable yield he
put it as inverted U shape I'm sure it
was the back of an end but I would had
to be and like that so basically he said
it's it's just as bad to Under fish as
it is to overfish the thing is you
should get that and the reason was he
said it's very healthy he must have been
a malthusian as well it's very healthy
to thin the fish populations because you
will then catch all the old infertile
fat fish and leave more space for the
young verile fish to
breed now I mean this must have struck
somebody as mad at the time but but it's
the the tragedy is it's still used to
determine how what amount of fish should
be caught out there it's crazy and
really it should be known and sent to
the Dustbin of stupid ideas but it went
into uncloth because there's a clause
there saying that any country that
technologically cannot catch to the
MSY has to make a long-term fishing
agreement with a foreign country that
can do that so as a result there are 300
or more fishing access agreements most
of which are
non-transparent not known to anybody
except the the negotiators and the
people who've the bribes and they've
resulted in the plunder of fish
populations all over the world
chronically as such and of course
governments including our own wonderful
government has often defended if they
ever get if if they longdistance Fishers
ever get any threat they come to their
aid against the developing country it is
a real uh uh shock
now the second pit about
fishing where uh Boris Johnson the late
lamented Boris Johnson was
characteristically economical with the
truth and we have a quota system quite a
few countries now have quota systems the
idea of a quota is that private property
rights lead to longterm investment
because your private property owners
will want to make long-term profits it's
a lousy Theory but that was the theory
is the theory and quota systems mean you
determine who which fishing company gets
what percentage of the total
catch so we have a system that began in
1967 actually but developed much later
and took refinement in the 1990s and
then refinement under under this last
government this current government and
we have a quota System whereby 25
companies uh own over 2 thirds of all
the fish in other words they can catch
all that fish but the little
people count five of them are in the
Sunday Times rich list they're among the
richest people in this country I wonder
why and the irony is that those big
industrial fishes have been caught
repeatedly in breaking the law and
there's a famous case in Scotland the
Blackfish scam of
2011 where they were caught some of the
biggest companies Landing 63 million
pound worth of clandestine overfished
illegally caught fish they were fined
but then allowed to keep their
quota now for me this is a ridiculous
thing it should be a crime okay you are
destroying nature you are destroying the
reproduction you're making sure that my
children your children won't have that
fish to to eat
so it's a real a real Scandal now I
won't go on there thr are more details
on that but what's happened with fishing
is the last part of the story because
increasingly Finance has moved in to
take control so we have a lovely concept
now slipper Skippers slipper Skippers
these are people who own the quota but
they lease it out to a big company a
finance company or behind the scene of
finance and they go off into Florida or
somewhere like that stay up on a Vera
and take the rents from the from the
fishing
now the last part of the fishing story
that I want to mention is that another
case of of Boris Johnson being
economical with the truth he claimed
that we have 26% of all our sea in
Marine protected areas we're the world
leader he said but as I show industrial
scale fishing is more intensive in our
marine protected areas than outsid it
with bottom trolling and destruction of
ecosystems and so on the Second Story to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas